because your body's hombre collisions
ruin your babe Beyonce watch out walking
back to glamour with me Josh Smith and
today we're joined by the brick alicia's
babes from lego movie Kristin Elizabeth
you're already getting involved in this
but today we're gonna challenge you to
recreate a portrait of the other using
Lego while I interview and distract you
I love it what would you say is your
best impression on stepping on a piece
of Lego what pain is worse than sucking
on a piece of Lego
is there one childbirth mmm I don't know
the jury's out of that one no your
characters are kind of like and this
love unrequited love going on what top
tips would you give someone who wants to
win someone over and get their attention
sometimes it's better to ignore someone
you know depends how many people adore
this person are they loved by everyone
ignore or don't give them the time of
day
and they'll be like hmm I need to get
that perfection something's off here
they're not they don't love me yeah but
if it's somebody who's like shy and
doesn't have a lot of suitors just be
honest to yourself and a couple of hath
leox brain in math yeah it's a double
flip don't know at the beginning Emmet
is seen as kind of like a helpless male
and the woman goes off to go get the
work done
yes I love personally right how
refreshing was that for you this Beth
well it's not refreshing it's the daily
life of that I live I think if you
really want to get something done ask a
woman that's sort of my philosophy in
general it's true what are the my other
favorite parts of this film is the spa s
world called the land of sparkles please
yes God like there you wait you look a
little bit like the very handsome
very funny lovely and voiced by a Brit
yeah well here we go
maybe it was me was it you plot spoiler
night Oh what is the beauty treatment
you guys have had in your lives you've
regretted the mouse is there one I had a
really bad feature once where they did
extraction and it looked like someone
took a red sharpie and just made dots
all over my really I once tried to do my
own makeup
you know because not well because I was
like it was early in my career when I'd
get makeup done and I think wow that
looked like I'd get it done for events
or something I'm and then I come home I
go that does look a lot better and so I
was gonna go to event and I did my own
makeup and it really looked like I
didn't have that subtle no I put the
wrong stuff on my I put mascara mascara
for your eyelashes I put it on my
eyebrows no and I even put some in my
mustache too to try to even it out it
was really bad look cool are you with
Gemma Collins the GC she's the real star
I mean I love that show I I watched when
I was out here shooting years ago got
hooked on it I'd be a little star-struck
if I met ya cuz she's on this stop have
you heard about that
no she's doing a dancing show on ice Wow
and she felt like flat down on the face
stop and she felt hard did she hurt
herself on her face oh no did she okay
I'm sorry no guys let's see the reveal I
want to see these portrays Wow Johnny I
gave you a little bit of Picasso they're
gonna see you in the nose area is that
do I have a cast I don't want to get out
your thighs I'm not gonna get insecure
about my nose that was so fun